So, here is example number one and I posted this on my Twitter and you can see that over
here we get a market structure shift, right?
And then we have this autoblock, very clean autoblock, most of you would say that, okay,
this is a very clean autoblock or a demand zone or whatever.
But notice what happens here, price sweeps the low here, even though we had a market structure
shift, we had this low as an inducement, we had this low, right?
We had a fair value gap.
Everything was saying, okay, go along.
But what happened?
Look, it just came back to the zero point, it swept the low, reclaimed, retest and it
took out this high.
So very, very easy trade.